tout c'est vrai comme on a dit on
aimerait que cette bataille judiciaire
soit rapide ce qu'on disait parce qu'on
aimerait que voilà il que l'un ou
l'autre puisse voilà continuer leur vie
parce que c'est vrai que c'est c'est là
ce soir par exemple voilà sur tlc ya le
spectacle d'art éviter en deuxième
partie de soirée ouais voilà et tmc
lagarde est à l'antenne je trouve que
pour l'instant moi je trouve ça très
bien voilà de la part de tmc parce que
voilà et je t'écris voilà et que pour
l'instant tant qu'il est présumé
innocent je pense qu'il faut qu'il
continue ses projets il faut qu'on
continue d'ailleurs est ce qu'il va
continuer à jouer son spectacle au gym
j'ai regardé dans plein de villes où il
doit faire sa tournée avec son spectacle
en début de l'année prochaine pour le
moment le spectacle est toujours à
l'affiché entre est encore loin des
billets j'ai regardé donc pour le moment
c'est vrai que on verra plus tard mais
pour le moment c'est tourné n'est pas
officiellement annulée en tout cas mais
alors guillaume je sais que pour il est
sorti du tribunal paris oui il a
actuellement confiné avec sa famille
dans un hôtel gens réfléchissent à une
stratégie de communication pour
envisager l'après peut-être la suite de
sa carrière moi j'ai eu longuement
l'avocat de la victime présumée il s'est
caché sous les sièges de la voiture
arrive parce qu'il avait tellement voilà
ils voulaient pas qu'on le voit quand il
est sorti du tribunal
voilà ses proches ont très peu de
nouvelles de lui ouais ce qu'on nous dit
ça c'est forme assez normal sa famille
ses enfants sont très très abattu par
cette affaire et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui voilà ton que voilà qu'on
n'a pas que que la sphère n'est pas
n'est pas réglé c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je trouve que tmc voilà
continue à diffuser le spectacle etc
pour l'instant attendons vraiment les
conclusions de l'enquêté et cette jeune
fille on espère aussi qu'elle va bien et
qu'elle qu'elle arrive à surmonter aussi
cette tempête médiatique parce que
forcément il ya des journalistes qui ont
réussi à la retrouver qui essaient de
l'appliquer c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué oui bernard est évidemment on
pense à la présumée victime comme on l'a
dit depuis le début et c'est terrible si
c'est vrai évidemment pense à elles et
cette douleur insupportable et
intolérable évidemment c'est condamnable
si c'est vrai mais ce que je voulais
dire c'est que sarah linky et sa
compagne depuis deux trois ans c'est
important de le dire elle le soutient ça
c'est quand ça c'est très important mais
elle le soutient à fond envers et contre
tous elle le dit elle le clame est le
soutien et elle n'y croit pas d'accord
là donc je répète présemption
d'innocence voilà donc sa compagne
actuelle le depuis trois ans sarah ligne
que tout le monde connaît une femme
adorable merveilleuse et je trouve
d'ailleurs très courageux qu'elle le
dise pas ce qu'elle aurait pu évidemment
mal de prendre puisque c'est une autre
jeune femme qu'il avait rencontrée entre
temps fac à me dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont et qu'ils connaissaient
déjà depuis quelques mois d'ailleurs
cette autre jeune femme donc voilà très
courageusement elle le dit à tout le
monde à tous nos amis que elle soutient
harry qu'elle n'y crois pas et je trouve
ça très fort de sa part en tout cas
laure guillot mh oui j'ai eu assez
longuement l'avocat de la victime donc
arash derambarsh équipe présumée victime
présumée qui mérite munich et plusieurs
informations la première information
c'est que cette affaire ne serait pas
uniquement une affaire de viol serait
également une affaire de violences il ya
eu des violences dont qui auraient été
perpétrés par ary abittan sur cette
jeune femme j'emploie évidemment le gros
pensionnat mais vous avez eu l'avocat
l'avocat parle d'une violence inouïe et
des blessures auraient été constaté par
lui-même j'ai donc l'unité médico
judiciaire la victime présumée c'est
donc une jeune femme de 21 ans elle est
étudiante elle se dit traumatisée
physiquement et moralement par les faits
elle n'est plus retournée en cours après
les faits et elle est recluse le mot est
fort rare plus selon son avocat et donc
elles souffrent beaucoup de cette
affaire il affirme aussi que c'est là
c'est pas la première fois qu'il voyait
qu'ils avaient une maison qui était
suivie et qui aurait déjà eu des faits
de ce type qui se seraient produits
entre ary abittan et cette jeune femme
il termine en disant que pour des prêts
des faits présumés de viol donc aggravé
de violence ils risqueraient jusqu'à 15
ans de réclusion criminelle voilà ça
c'est la version de l'avocat on précise
car les habitants réfute cette version
nature voilà on met lass est l'avocat
des ressources humaines merci marc
désert bien sûr il faut avoir et de
version il ya eu la version
hier voilà deux du clan dari